well the exploding coronavirus pandemic
is upending thanksgiving traditions but
millions of americans are determined to
celebrate hitting the road at a time
when health officials want us to stay at
home more than 2200 coveted related
deaths were reported yesterday the
highest one-day toll
in more than six months the virus has
altered another thanksgiving tradition
the nfl postponed tonight's raven
steelers game after some baltimore
players
and staff tested positive the midwest
continues to have the highest rate of
new infections
adriana diaz is outside a hospital in
hard hit chicago
adriana good morning good morning guys
and happy thanksgiving doctors here at
northwestern memorial hospital say
they're more prepared for this latest
surge
but the wave of patients is coming in
faster than in the spring
the covert population has more than
doubled here in the last two weeks
filling a second cova dedicated icu and
one doctor warned that infections over
thanksgiving
could lead to deaths by christmas
i expected to be celebrating with my
92 year old mother but that's not going
to happen
this year officials across the country
like chicago mayor lori lightfoot
made one last plea to americans
wednesday safety first
on thanksgiving the city's public health
commissioner pointed to canada
as a warning sign canada celebrated its
thanksgiving six weeks ago
since then the number of covet cases
diagnosed per day
has more than doubled the u.s rates of
cases
right now are much worse than canada's
was
but in some places the surge is already
here
yesterday california set a nationwide
record for the most
new infections reported in a single day
i am not going to lie i am nervous to
see what happens
in topeka kansas the stormont veil
hospital is at capacity
and they're expecting a 20 percent
increase of covert patients
in the next two weeks the cdc recently
took a look at kansas's mask mandate
saying it's proof masks work counties
that implemented a mask mandate
saw a six percent drop in cases counties
that didn't
saw cases rise 100 percent one person
who learned how important masks are in a
devastating way
is a neil garmalker what was your view
on the virus before you got sick
versus now really didn't think it would
have the effect it did on me
the former truck driver would normally
have been hauling turkeys over the last
few months
instead he's at home breathing through a
tracheotomy tube in his throat
he says his main concern when he got
sick was his family
i mean the last thing i thought and i
prayed
scared that i you know i had infected my
wife and
my kids and my mom you don't
think that you're gonna be a widow at 33
but that was
a reality i had to face at that time
that's why doctors are urging us all to
be safe this thanksgiving and listen to
this
here at northwestern doctors say many of
their covet patients
got infected at small gatherings at home
that's why they say with cases as high
as they are you should assume everyone
you come in contact with outside your
household
could be contagious eureka yeah these
stories just don't get any easier to
listen to adriana thank you